salut tout le monde et veut bien venu
pour ce nouveau blitz à lui fabien salut
kiev dont certaines parties entre
l'ouest les sauts et magnus carlsen
essais partout donc cavalier f3 pour
wesley so et magnus carlsen qui est déjà
en train de réfléchir dans ce blitz e
fabien quel est alors j'ai 53 ans mais
sont évidents des 4,5 ne peut pas jouer
ne rapportent ils rentrent dans une dans
une ue hollandaises ont peut-être
winstone au mur de pierre pokémon de
niveau carrasco c'est très dur à
détruire travailleurs mais bon moi c'est
ce qui amène ses pokémon enlève trois
essais trois ils sont là ils se battent
bien les cavaliers sont bien placés et
il contrôle le centre fabien mais
qu'elle va être l'idée pour les blancs
ici tu as tort ils échangent défaut de
cases noires parce qu'on voit des 15
mars on peut trouver 5 c5 tout ça et
laisse donc les normes et leur mauvais
tout s'est vite bon mauvais foot ou
relatifs qui a deux options sortir par
granby 6 x 6 ou encore dans tout ça on
s'en fout 17.8 tfou h 5 points
depuis c'est fabien le fou de cases
blanches des blancs même si c'est le bon
fou il ya un petit peu emmuré dans le
mur de pierre c'est ça c'est ça c'est un
peu l'idée de stonewall qui qui est
encore une des rares ouvertures dans
laquelle les ordinateurs ne comprennent
pas grand chose donc jouable juste sur
la compréhension sans se prendre des
prépas de ouf ou quoi donc ça va être
une ouverture intéressante à un haut
niveau
quand on sait pas trop quoi joue et
qu'on joue contre un très bon théoricien
fabien éventuellement et on sait que que
wesley so est l'un des meilleurs
théoriciens à haut niveau aujourd'hui
complètement alors la question du choix
peut-être des menaces pour donner la
taille de 6 à ces flamands medhat il
veut tout claquer en dessin pour faire à
la fois une double attaque et encaisser
la tour en a huit qui est bien triste de
fond tous défendent kurys avec le
feuilleton des 5 avec adam voilà on sent
quand même un karl scène trois mètres
derrière sa ligne de fond de court
fabien à ce soit mais bon si tu mets une
bonne balle liftée avec du rebond pour
regagner du terrain peut-être difficile
sur sept cette saison gazon on voit
qu'ils jouent sur un sur un échiquier
vers fabien on va quand même faire
attention
du coup
il partira ensuite il s'est un petit peu
caché de la diagonale de la dame la dame
en russe est solide web apps tour des
géants des trucs comme ça concerne les
pylônes et adèle royco pas du tout sur
le coup droit
pilonnée finalement sur cette colonne
c'est vrai que les noirs ont du mal à
lier leur tour donc ça peut être
intéressant cette idée fabien non mais
c'est pas bête on va dire peut-être de
jeu c'est prendre des cinq au moment
opportun c'est énorme reprennent de ces
envers la colonne cécile reprennent deux
heures d'avion c6 un peu arriérés
c'est un peu l'effet de sa droite à
gauche le califat revenir avec trois ou
cinq donc annonce quand même je te pas
si simple en fait juste attaqué à
lectoure gien et tout ça parce que
finalement tu passes tes pièces que tu
attaques un peu le vide donc sûrement
mieux ce que fait son excuse pour être
intéressant à est un excuse moi mais
étonnant ce coup h 6 2 de magnus qui
vient affaiblir la 4g si ce n'est
peut-être cavalière trois cavaliers 5 à
décaler l'idée me suis peut-être juste
trouver ton martial angers sont du coup
il veut clairement prendre en 5 cl
cavalli bien se placer sur un bon bah
othon et après on pourra peut-être
reprendre de f du coup il y aura un pion
de 5 et faire cavalier bessin qui a aidé
6 fab 32 comme ça tu donnes la caisse
des quatre sont intéressants et il est
pas mal
il est pas mal wesley là le champion du
monde magnus carlsen non en légère
difficulté fabien alors que logan moi je
pense que les personnes sont quatre
prises vous reprendre 2f et faire
pression sur la f2 faut quand même
prendre du fou jusqu'à cavaliers
position fermée car il doit dominer les
oeuvres et attention parce que si on
prend le temps de faire fois ci c'est du
genre pour ces quatre coups des trois
trucs comme ça le choix concède thomas
la fois ci c'est ce qu'il a fait ce
qu'on peut faire fouet f1 mais bon dans
ces cas-là on perdrait tout le bénéfice
de du cavalier mais bon en même temps tu
vois pas trop le choix il a fait une
mauvaise circulation je sais pas ce
qu'ils au tournant quand même quand même
assez impressionnant la part de
de ma news carlsen retournement de
situation parce qu'il était vraiment
avec toutes ces pièces sur les huitièmes
ranger et en l'espace de deux trois
coups anodins h6 qu'à aider cet échange
gagnant le cas tout d'un coup la partie
tourne quatre bombes un sacré tremplin
quelque part très technique du losange
avec le cavalier site mathis et si on
jouait au go en fait le cavaliere quatre
seraient perdus parler parler parler
bissau s'est trompé de jeu même temps il
voulait pas affronter alpha bout une
salle face aux halles faso une lettre
aurait beaucoup plus fort du coup alpha
carlson maquiller comme saddam en h4 et
qui vient ainsi de taper le plus rage 2
web hautement à damas trois sortes de
double tacle facilement défendable dans
le ciel je crois que les marques
commencent a déjà tant mieux ça commence
à être difficile ce campus à tout
revient sur la colonne ouverte on as dû
dame prend un jeu dame c2 et dames c'est
un auteur d'un bras 7 bis bon ben j'ai
pas proche d'eux alors à trois et cinq
minutes les matches du couloir mais
manon et et dames de dames 3 3 il
attaque la base du losange pas mais très
très important quant à losanges de
prendre le pion de base hors d'alger
deux arrivées juste pousser les pions h
en fait il garde son losange a peut-être
dans ce dossier non c'est une autre
option ne me promener je suis né ici je
sais pas qui est double attaque là j'ai
un son qui nous faire la vidéo il a
lâché side f2 pour achat pour le culte 2
en losange mance plus qu'un petit
triangle équilatéral et il menace damas
quatre échecs en plus menacé une double
attaque de 4,1 défendez 6 au passage des
cages avec ton losange et l'annexé 4 6 2
je pensais dams et 4 dames ces systèmes
pour jeudi phie tous très bons veut pas
prendre de risque il peut faire des
quatre aussi à la limite et on voyait
bout
mais la smat attention ils défendent pas
d'accord il s'était un peu pacifié même
temps de coeur de reprendre la colonne
c'est au noir que s'il revient en tant
matériellement on en est où il ya six
pions noirs quatre pions de de plus
tourné mais ok détroit qui prend le pion
et puis le losange va disparaître en
fait la c6 tour prendra aussi le premier
trio des dames prend ombrage à la finale
en charge et 50 pouces
tran décide de ne pas faire dame c'est
un échec en premier ses droits sur un
bon photo dc c'est maintenant dams un
échec dame secal voilà c'est un tour de
magie
la dame s'est replacé les mains dans les
poches f4 alors du coup il faut faut
être un peu technique mais à trois pions
passé lié quand même voilà ça fait
beaucoup
des cinq réfléchir s est joué ces jouets
d'assaut il peut plus faire grand chose
je pense qu'à bientôt abandonnée à
fabien body language d'ailleurs une
instruction sur le reculoir presque ils
seront quatre pions quand même dans la
figure et se les pions e et f ils sont
liés
les deux vont pousser en fait du coup le
roi est complètement protégé par
j'essaie th 6 il tente le tout pour le
tout avec son pion femmes mais bon au
final 4-4 qui ont bossé lit ça fait
beaucoup en plus ces plans sont plus
avancées attention c'est la tour qui
piège de hongrois qui protègent ils vont
f3 à f2 f1 ça va tout seul pour bloquer
les g5 peut-être d'amd 5 e st attention
cette tour prime 4
ta meuf 5 5 4 mais ça ça avance tout
seul fab contenant du beurre et du
beurre qui n'a pas passé longtemps
réfrigérateur très fondre ouais tu vas
faire là dessus avec un petit couteau en
plastique c'est ça ça marche
ouais aucun doigt ça marche tout le koup
il va il va abandonner la belle victoire
de magnus